[Music]
33 seconds for two logos repetitious
green light ball but boring
it takes nine cuts for this movie to
explain how compasses well channel three
where I live it's public access and it
never has anything remotely as
interesting as this it's mostly local
sermons be music and broadcasts of City
Council meetings or Cheryl the town nag
repeatedly disses the City Council just
because she can also since he doesn't
jump upon seeing the jigsaw mask thingy
guy I guess this guy doesn't see the
last movie Oh to be him for a day how
much blood will you should just stay
alive Michael the key is and Michael's
eye socket that he's been presented the
easiest choice in this series so far on
pure adrenaline loan this dude should be
able to cut out the key and save himself
but this is Saul we're talking about
here editing credits shared by Marvel
films and over-caffeinated Stanley and
meth this movie is actively telling me
you right now you've got nothing to
complain about dude not only are you
possibly the stupidest song victim in
history you've got well more than a
minute to cut your stupid eyeball Wow
holy Sh they made do with these things
also I'll tell you right now this movie
is expecting me to remember anything
from the first Saw movie then movie has
vastly overestimated my investment
Donnie Wahlberg's like why can't I get a
call from Scorsese I was into 6/10 mark
thought the Vietnam War was still going
on in 1988 give me a frickin break here
but Donnie's at a crossroads in his
career here at a point directly between
the Sixth Sense and dating Jenny
McCarthy and believe it or not those are
the only three data points we need to
create an accurate line graph of his
career trajectory your mother gets to
keep custody I get to take you into
custody the guy that wrote this line was
so proud of himself he literally suck
his own dick right after sadly he choked
to death on his own ejaculate which even
the coroner noted was ironic and yet
still somehow appropriate please save
him the after-school special why is this
a cop 20 hey movie mocking after-school
specials is doing a pretty good job of
imitating one this guy smokes all the
cigarettes this transition seems cool
but really just feels like his room was
in a studio and he's merely walking into
another part of the studio hey Starship
Troopers girl still getting work good
for you I've already sold this case the
victim died because he was stupid but
closer detective Mathews
asked already and somehow he immediately
looks to the ceiling after all that
cryptic and after she looks to the left
oh wait is there a tape of this remember
the TV earlier I'm not even sure it's
plugged up or anything but that's beside
the point
there's no B C are there and this TV
definitely isn't one of those tv/vcr
combo thing
while hunting the jigsaw killer this
precinct is also still looking for
Travis Bickel Igor an old pierce brosnan
her my wife's divorce lawyers I'd say my
hands are pretty full wouldn't full of
cliches yes Louie spends daytime soap
opera dollars on big dream flashback
sequence which is to say they actually
collected 3:45 from the assembled idiots
who participated in a shooting of the
scene the big thing this guy thinks
about is the fucking steel company logo
that was on the death mask
that's like tracking down the serial
killer who uses pennies to murder people
and saying AHA he's been giving us Clues
all along do the Denver Mint 10 own in
teams of three
but with Team Alpha thanks for the
completely useless seemingly exciting
dialogue stream SWAT dude we've never
met and we'll never see you again good
luck with Team Alpha
whatever that means just like the good
old days huh did they like literally
only have three days to shoot this I'm
gonna loss to explain the nests of this
movie considering there are about six
sequels after this one team I won you in
front faker okay Baker here's probably a
dude but following the Alpha Team order
you think a Bravo team order would be
next
but apparently Baker is the only member
of Team Bravo and therefore his orders
are given to him by name as opposed to
the standard operating procedure used
with the Alpha team's instructions oh
man I bet that looked painful
also these dumbasses go into a place
that is obviously booby-trapped and
don't get any specialists to come check
out stuff like this before walking into
unknown areas I never really considered
it before but yes yes I think this is
true this movie has more stare action
than Batman V Superman The Ultimate
Edition after all this these dumbasses
run up the stairs figuring well there's
one booby trap definitely won't be more
is this close enough haha I sold your
clever steel company glue hahaha three
dots on jigsaw here and only two
assholes with guns here I think that's
my son you think where is he that's a
problem you're gonna have to solve
before it's too late
I know jigsaw has a few followers who
help him but how did he learn enough
about these people to decide these
people must go through my dastardly cool
puzzles he may have read some things
heard some things but to know them
intimately enough to know they needed to
be hooked up to death machines
oh yes there will be blood roll credit
also I drink your milkshake
also I'm pretty sure this is the dude
the first movie said was the killer
which makes me both not trust him right
now and assume some other unseen weirdo
is the actual killer in this movie but
mostly whatever tell me where he is he's
in a safe place
well that's enough for me I need to go
make some phone calls
it's fall he's not in right now well he
even changed Daniels outgoing message I
gotta give it to jigsaw man this guy
pays attention to every detail even ones
that don't matter we have something
coming down over here gimme Bomb Squad
now just now notice the countdown for
some reason even though it's in full
view for everybody to see let me stop
bitching about it and let's do stuff
this is an argument the screenwriters
had when they were writing this movie
yet another movie that thinks viewers
need or want to see characters puking on
screen movie rips off national treasure
brick based clue pay off everything you
need to know false you mean to say most
of the things you know but there's no
way this tape recorder from the wall
contains any information about this
guy's brother fucking his wife behind
his back or about the bus that will not
be able to slow down who is this well
first off he never said gasps he said
nerve agent but you were clever enough
to solve the math on that one and second
off are you kidding me do not attempt to
use this key on the door to this room
these characters are immediately
unlikable and dangerously stupid and
maybe that's the point but it doesn't
make for an enjoyable movie experience
when your eyes are constantly rolling
wait a minute was that the trap for this
door if you use the key this required
one dumbass to turn the key and another
dumbass to look in the peephole for it
to work unless jigsaw was expecting the
guy who turned the key to also be
looking in the peephole which is also
not likely even jigsaws minions played
the pronoun game because that plate well
I immediately don't trust this chicken
think she's in on it 150 million now
find out what happened to Scott McLean
after seven minutes of watching the feed
this guy finally asks for a team to
check where the feed is coming from and
where's that bomb squad he ordered seven
minutes ago
never once does this guy try the knob of
this door they all assume it's locked
and hey I would too but I'm definitely
trying it at least once maybe with my
head and body safely out of the way
there's no way that John's voice can be
heard like this over a walkie talkie
when he's 5 feet away from it and it's
on the ground if you're gonna use this
bat to break through the double door is
this the first place you've take away
wouldn't you hit it as close to the
doorknobs as possible as close to the
locking mechanism as possible why hit
one door eight inches in and a foot up
up a walk are you going for a here's
Johnny opening also Dave hi this asshole
still hasn't tried the knob yet hey I
pushed on stuff and it worked out I mean
if you found a door it's guarantee
that torturer clown asshole wanted you
to find it right how do you not even
suspect this at this point
this isn't acting this is actually a
candid moment between actresses as
seventh heaven girl frantically hopes
the brunette can give her any kind of
insight into the flimsy script of this
movie oh I don't know but let's tear
that possible clue up because the
shredded piece of paper beats an intact
piece of paper any day laura somehow
remembers the dude who kidnapped her
even though she never turns around in
season and it's dark and he's in the
backseat of a car right now you're going
in you stay ladies and gentlemen acting
i understand everyone in this warehouse
has the intelligence of a coked-out
guinea pig but absolutely nobody seems
to understand they're in a situation
that requires slightly more thought than
simply crawling headfirst into an
incinerator and these guys have a
flashlight too it's not like they
couldn't scoop this thing out first
before diving in entirely too many
minutes of a dude burning alive you
should feel bad movie exactly what we
should be doing until the tech team gets
here yeah okay but why was the tech team
five states away and why aren't they
here yet are they traveling by Segway
movie who tries to make us feel sympathy
for this apparent jigsaw killer guy by
giving us the MTV super cut version of
his Walter White cancer diagnosis did
you remember that Cary Elwes character
from song was named dr. Lawrence Gordon
because I did not so how did I write
this in I did not write this in I had
literally driven myself suicide and I
had failed so I decided that if I can't
kill myself I'll kill others you'd have
done the same in my place
and I was determined to spend the rest
of my days testing the fabric of human
nature I survived a car wreck while also
having cancer so therefore I decided to
throw people into much more difficult
torture puzzles because of something to
do with man's lost survival instinct
which we don't use as much today because
we're not cavemen being chased by lions
and tigers anymore which was a much
better time I guess does it don't
appreciate life do not deserve life so
basically everyone but the double
rainbow guy then no we don't have 15
minutes see this countdown got 23
minutes closer after four minutes of
jigsaw telling his life story we should
stop discount middle school Casey
Affleck is right you should keep moving
how did this chick even think to check
the couch wounds for I told you earlier
she's in on it and here is just more
proof who does that thanks for this by
the way movie
we found it don't do the did you just
come in here out of breath looking like
you've been stabbed or about to throw up
and now that no one here you're running
and how useless is a jump-scare and the
Saw movies the tractor because she's
stupid for saying something obvious
whatever's behind this door can't hurt
me jigsaw makes these assholes dig for a
key in a pool of used needles and this
is where I get off kids do you realize
how many stops and robberies jigsaw must
have committed to even gather this many
used needles it's like eight months of
work easy I know he's a puzzle killer
who plans ahead but this is sheer lunacy
which I guess people love since this is
only the first of about 15 sequels also
why only four minutes to complete this
task with a minute or two spent on the
audio tape you're already making a guy
swimming aids to get this why the
impossible time limit hope the actual
the fact that this movie continues from
here without any of the witnesses to
this horrific act attacking that dude is
wrong as hell and it takes an already
flimsy premise and dips it in a pool of
the unbelievable let's talk this out no
no what do you guys have done almost no
talking god oh yeah I totally murder
toss that girl in the needle pit so what
step to me hilariously in order to
prepare for this scene Donnie just
recalled the new kids meeting with the
label after they got dropped honestly
he's still pissed about that in real
life which is why he won't let Jenny
McCarthy vaccinate her dogs what also
for the record he is literally
destroying evidence because he's mad
under the watch of armed police guards
who supposedly know the difference
between right and wrong detectives
arrived only took an hour you know how
hard it is to haul computers wrong desk
you mean they haven't checked these
desks yet how the ever-loving fuck with
this killer or any human being know that
Donnie Wahlberg planted evidence on all
these criminals this movie takes the
villain knowing unknowable to a
transcendent plane of the fifth
dimension I mean Jesus Christ here
people exactly how much bolder we is a
film going public going to tolerate in
the name of a decent fright this guy
accidentally uncovers this guy's hat and
then accidentally remembers the joke's
on clue about the combination even
though he's been nothing but a dimwit
asshole this whole movie meanwhile the
character set up to be smarter than him
aren't thinking about Jax honestly a
chest bursting alien could leap out of
this guy right now and I wouldn't bat an
eye that's how batshit crazy this
movie's been so far and how shamelessly
it steals from other movies including
saw unsure the true jigsaw killer also
planned for these two to go from
conversation to knife fight in three
seconds time well I don't know what's
gonna happen next but I feel confident
labeling this a convenient sea
pretty sure the last thing you're
supposed to do when someone has a
seizure is hold their neck in place not
that this chick would know that since
all these people are grade-a idiots but
whatever this movie is also trying to
make me believe this dude is going to
memorize all the numbers he comes across
Oh
pathetic is this tech teaming there like
an hour or more late then they take
forever so that this asshole has to
watch a son maybe die
I mean mr. bean would be more effective
in this movies tech team I'll take no
real police force would allow to happen
for 800 Alex also thinking a game
playing motherfucker like this gives two
shits about being beaten up come on
Donny didn't you see The Dark Knight
three years from now on a dying win this
girl goes down the hall and into this
room and wouldn't you know it jigsaw has
the perfect little death scenario
planned and plotted out for LA because
this assholes can God apparently even if
she's forgetting caution because she's
so weak and dazed from the nerve agent
this illustrates why this movie's traps
haven't been one bit of fun which is the
whole reason you want to saw a movie if
you're into that kind of thing every
single victim is either too stupid to
realize what they need to do or they've
been killed by something or someone else
or jigsaw has made the trap too hard to
solve in time so I give up to all the
non-epileptic sout there hope you
enjoyed that
I fucking strobe best to all the
epileptics in the audience on behalf of
the movie I apologize that you had to
see them
absolutely nobody saw that Eric and John
got into an elevator until they were
already going down on it wait all this
time you never secured the warehouse
you're in what is this just some lazy
copy-paste screenwriting going on here
I'm in tithing every single one of these
motherfucking cops on charges of
aggressive incompetence for not checking
the very goddamn building they've been
standing in the whole motherfucking time
goddamn this pisses me off
and finally you guys been sucked by the
way thanks for being useless to everyone
with a screenwriter carry such timing
what coincidence much luck
well good thing was murdered in this
very room enteric suddenly trust jigsaw
like guess because he thinks is beating
100% worked on that psychopath it's
really too bad this group of criminals
and strangers couldn't work together in
the two hours jigsaw cave he was trying
to teach teamwork damn it dude that guy
really knows how to cut off a piece of
his neck perfectly with no mirrors and
even better he cut precisely around the
number that was written on it but then
that piece of brilliance is totally
negated by this kid slitting the
students throat immediately after it
happens the scene is symbolic of the
this movie provides this person put a
horse mask on and lay in a bathtub
waiting for Eric to show up and this is
some tongue because first off there was
no guarantee he would have walked into
this place and second off dude has a gun
I know you want to be scary and
everything but this could have easily
backfire the big reveal Daniel was in
that room the whole time and the footage
they saw wasn't live but on tapes it's
actually a really good ending a fun
ending but you put us through a whole
bunch of yelling and fighting and
stupidity to get us here just because
you've been stinking up the house
cooking swamp rats doesn't mean we get
excited when you put a pizza in front of
us I might have to fix that metaphor
also how did he not wake up before now
or ever make a noise okay forget I found
myself a father a leader a teacher more
surprises Amanda was working for jigsaw
all along but first let's put her in a
room full of criminals one who's a
murderer also I guess she can be a
surprise reveal later I mean I guess she
was supposed to help Daniel stay alive
during all that that's another plan that
kind of backfire what's the movie of
Daniel dies
what does jigsaws point if he ended up
getting killed it is I who will carry on
John's work after he dies for one movie
also see I told you
game over wait a minute why isn't the
SWAT team running around in this
building right now isn't the van with
jigsaw and the passenger seat still
parked outside somewhere they're just
never gonna find this place I am the
funnel
[Music]
know what a little water in this pain
should you know me I would paint water
and just about everything that I do
[Music]
game over
you know they know an adult finish when
everybody got AIDS
[Music]
we here at cinemasins love working with
our brand partners last month lootcrate
sent us a box of speed now well not that
kind of speed this kind of speed and you
can get your very own box of speed or
other nerd memorabilia by subscribing to
loot crate October's loot crate theme is
war and if you subscribe by October 1990
a.m. Pacific time you can receive all
the creepy crawlies ouki scary blood and
gory themed loot in this month's loot
crate you'll get six to eight items it's
less than $20 a month and if you sign up
at loot crate comm slash cinemasins and
enter code cinemasins you can save 10%
but what if you want sweet geek and
gamer dear but live somewhere like
Australia Mexico South Africa
good news loot crate ships to over 28
countries around the world so sign up at
Luke great calm slash cinemasins and
enter code cinemasins by 9 p.m. Pacific
on October 19th ticket October's whole
loot crate it's to die for
[Music]